[Música]
rusia utiliza los alimentos como un arma
contra ucrania así lo denunció el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken afirmó que las tropas rusas
tienen como rehén a los suministros e
impiden las exportaciones de granos al
tiempo que el senado estadounidense
aprobó un nuevo paquete de ayudas por 40
mil millones de dólares para untar
después de casi dos años por fuera de
españa- el rey emérito juan carlos
primero regresó a su país natal luego de
que fuera archivada la investigación por
presunto fraude fiscal y blanqueo de
capitales
el antiguo monarca vive en emiratos
árabes desde agosto de 2020 cuando
iniciaron las investigaciones
conectaremos con madrid
y la guerra en ucrania es protagonista
en el festival de cannes hoy se presentó
un documental que relata cómo se vive en
un barrio de mariupol una de las
ciudades ucranianas más bombardeadas
el filme de hecho es un homenaje a su
codirector asesinado en esa urbe tenemos
reportes desde francia
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
gusto acompañarlos empezamos en eeuu
porque el senado aprobó el paquete de
40.000 millones de dólares para
respaldar a ucrania con 86 votos a favor
y tan solo 11 en contra los legisladores
probaron una unidad que pocas veces se
ha visto en proyectos propuestos por el
gobierno de joe biden la semana pasada a
la cámara de representantes- le dio el
aval con
368 votos a favor y 57 en contra por lo
que el paquete ya queda en pie más de la
mitad del dinero es decir 24 mil
millones son para armar y equipar a las
fuerzas ucranianas 9 mil millones para
el gobierno de kiev y 5 mil millones
para ayudas alimentarias a los países
que dependen de los cultivos que ucrania
no ha podido exportar
en esa línea de eeuu acusó a rusia de
utilizar los alimentos como un arma
contra ucrania ante el consejo de
seguridad de la onu el secretario de
estado de la casa blanca- anthony
blinken afirmó que moscú tomó como rehén
el suministro de millones de ucranianos
conjuntamente rusia y ucrania producen
casi un tercio del trigo que se consume
en todo el mundo escuchemos a blick
y
la federación rusa afirma falsamente que
las sanciones de la comunidad
internacional son las culpables del
empeoramiento de la crisis alimentaria
mundial
las sanciones no están bloqueando los
puertos del mar negro atrapando barcos
llenos de alimentos y destruyendo las
carreteras y vías férreas de ucrania
sino rusia las sanciones no están
vaciando los silos de granos ucranianos
y el robo de equipos agrícolas
ucranianos rusia lo está haciendo las
sanciones no impiden que rusia exporta
alimentos y fertilizantes las sanciones
impuestas por eeuu y muchos otros países
incluyen deliberadamente la exclusión de
alimentos fertilizantes y semillas de
rúsia
sin formar avanza la diplomacia de
suecia y finlandia para entrar a la otan
este jueves la primera ministra sueca
magdalena anderson y el presidente
finlandés saúl y ministo se reunieron
con el mandatario joe biden en la casa
blanca para discutir la adhesión a la
alianza militar
turquía que es el país que se opone
estaría a la espera de concesiones de
armas y de que los nórdicos rechacen al
partido de los trabajadores kurdistán
conocido como pepe cap para revertir su
postura y respaldar la decisión unánime
que se necesita en la otan rodrigo
ciudadano nos cuenta qué pasó en
washington
una visita en la casa blanca que podría
ser preámbulo de una nueva era
estratégica para la otan el presidente
de finlandia saúl y ninis pto y la
primera ministra sueca magdalena
anderson se reunieron con el presidente
joe biden de gira tras entregar sus
solicitudes para entrar en la alianza
atlántica en rayas azules que el
agresión james de sobre la agresión rusa
a gran escala contra un vecino soberano
y democrático fue un momento decisivo
para suecia y mi gobierno ha llegado a
la conclusión de que la seguridad del
pueblo sueco estará mejor protegida
dentro de la alianza de la otan
es una decisión aplaudida por el
mandatario estadounidense
y hoy me enorgullece asegurarles que
cuentan con el respaldo total total y
completo de los eeuu de américa
hoy mi administración está presentando
el congreso de eeuu informes sobre la
atención al otan de ambos países para
que el senado pueda pasar rápidamente a
asesorar y consentir el tratado pero es
necesario que los 30 aliados de la otan
den el sí y turquía lanzó su veto
argumentando que éstos protegen
terroristas los nórdicos están abiertos
al diálogo
como aliados de la otan nos
comprometeremos con la seguridad de
turquía al igual que turquía se
comprometerá con nuestra seguridad nos
sumamos el terrorismo en serio el futuro
geoestratégico de suecia y finlandia
está ligado al de los kurdos de turquía
y siria según ankara protegen a miembros
del pkk el partido de los trabajadores
del kurdistán declarado como terrorista
por turquía y las jbg filias del pkk en
el norte de siria y aliado de eeuu en la
lucha contra el estado islámico ankara
estaría condicionando su veto a
concesiones sobre este tema y también ha
hablado sobre el embargo de armas de
ambos países tras la ofensiva turca
sobre el norte de siria en 2019
avanza el primer juicio por posibles
crímenes de guerra cometidos en ucrania
el soldado ruso acusado pidió perdón a
la familia de la víctima un civil de 62
años al que le disparó como el mismo
militar ruso lo aceptó mientras la
fiscalía pide cadena perpetua les
contamos más en el siguiente informe
por favor dime te arrepentiste el crimen
que cometiste
si admito mi culpabilidad entiendo que
no podrás perdonarme pero te pido perdón
es el segundo día de un juicio de gran
importancia simbólica para ucrania el
primero por crímenes de guerra desde la
invasión rusa el acusado badín sí sí
marín pidió perdón a la viuda de
oleksandr se lee pop de 62 años en el
cuarto día de la invasión rusa así si
marín le disparó en la cabeza pese a ser
un civil desarmado
tenía un disparo en la cabeza corrí
hacia él y se veía su cerebro bueno el
cráneo estaba perforado
el hecho ocurrió en la localidad de
chupa kit acá en el noreste ucraniano
algo que el acusado admitió durante el
primer día del juicio según sisi marín
vieron al hombre hablar por teléfono y
un oficial le obligó a disparar porque
podría dar la alerta al ejército
ucraniano él ordenó disparar yo no
disparé y entonces otro oficial que
estaba al lado del conductor se dio la
vuelta y comenzó a ordenar me en tono
amenazante que disparará o que de lo
contrario no alcanzaríamos a nuestras
tropas y no podríamos pedir refuerzos y
que estábamos en peligro con tan sólo 21
años y si marín era sargento y
comandante de un tanque ahora tras
admitir su culpabilidad podría
enfrentarse a cadena perpetua el soldado
dice aceptar la pena la viuda así lo
pide si bien afirma que aceptaría un
intercambio por prisioneros de atos tal
otro juicio que protagoniza las noticias
internacionales es el de peyton gendron
el hombre blanco estadounidense acusado
de asesinar a 10 personas afroamericanas
en un supermercado en búfalo esto en el
estado de nueva york él compareció ante
el tribunal hoy después de que un gran
jurado lo acusara de asesinato en primer
grado que permaneció en silencio durante
el procedimiento al que asistieron
algunos familiares de las víctimas
recordemos que ese sábado 13 personas en
total recibieron disparos 11 de ellas
eran afrodescendientes y todavía
continúan investigando la posibilidad de
imputarle adentro en cargos por delitos
de odio y de terrorismo
y una serie de casos de una enfermedad
llamada viruela del mono han sido
reportados en eeuu y en varios países
europeos esta enfermedad se da sobre
todo en áfrica occidental y central y
sólo muy ocasionalmente se propaga a
otros lugares sin embargo el brote ya ha
generado alarmas y en perú por ejemplo
se declaró la alerta sanitaria por esta
enfermedad sin embargo todavía no se ha
detectado ningún caso en el siguiente
reporte les explicamos de qué se trata
la viruela del mundo
la viruela del mono es una enfermedad
rara los síntomas incluyen una erupción
costras además de fiebre dolores
musculares ganglios linfáticos
inflamados escalofríos y agotamiento se
han registrado decenas de casos en
varios países europeos desde portugal y
españa- hasta suecia y reino unido se
trata de una enfermedad grave pero no
altamente infecciosa para los humanos
strange bing xing la cepa que se está
viendo en el actual brote en europa es
la cepa de áfrica occidental que tiene
una tasa de mortalidad de
aproximadamente 1 de cada 100 won en
sangre el departamento de salud pública
de massachusetts dice que ha confirmado
un caso en un hombre que viajó
recientemente a canadá
este paciente está ingresado en nuestro
programa especial de patógenos
actualmente se encuentra en condiciones
estables en este bucle de semen el
paciente se encuentra bien con seguridad
en aislamiento en nuestra unidad
actualmente no hay cura para la viruela
del mono está estrechamente relacionada
con la viruela que fue erradicada hace
décadas la vacuna contra la viruela
puede dar cierta protección
para understand y realmente necesitamos
entender mejor el alcance de la viruela
del mono en países endémicos como la
república democrática del congo y
nigeria la república centroafricana y
otros para entender realmente cuánto
está circulando y el riesgo que supone
para las personas que viven allí así
como el riesgo de exportación los casos
recientes en el reino unido se
produjeron predominantemente entre
hombres que tienen relaciones sexuales
con hombres todavía no se ha determinado
si el inusual aumento de casos fuera de
áfrica indica un cambio en el virus o en
los medios de propagación el rey emérito
de españa juan carlos primero regresó
por primera vez a su país natal casi dos
años después de irse a abu dhabi en
medio de las investigaciones por
presunto fraude fiscal todos los
detalles los tiene nuestra corresponsal
en madrid marina colorado
el rey emérito juan carlos de 84 años
llegó a españa en avión privado poco
después de las 7 de la tarde a vigo en
el noroeste del país donde pasará el fin
de semana asistiendo a una competición
de veleros han pasado casi dos años
desde que pisó suelo español cuando en
agosto de 2020 se fue a vivir a emiratos
árabes unidos- huyendo de la presión de
la justicia que dos meses antes habría
un tercer caso en su contra por
irregularidades fiscales según el
emérito que abdicó en 2014 este cambio
de vivienda lo hizo para facilitarle la
tarea a su hijo el rey felipe sexto en
marzo de este año la fiscalía española
archivó todos los casos en contra de
juan carlos de borbón pero no porque no
se hubieran encontrado indicios de
delito sino porque los hechos habían
prescrito o se cometieron mientras el
emérito gozaba de inmunidad como monarca
esto espejo el camino para su regreso al
territorio del que fue rey durante 39
años el lunes vendrá a madrid donde se
reunirá con el rey felipe sexto en el
palacio de la zarzuela residencia
oficial de la familia real ese mismo día
volverá de regreso a aguda ha sido una
figura clave durante la transición
democrática en españa pero que levanta
mucha polémica mientras que desde el
partido socialista en el gobierno piden
que dé explicaciones la vertiente más de
izquierdas del gobierno de coalición en
la unión de unidas podemos pide que
rinda cuentas ante la justicia y que se
reabra el debate de la inviolabilidad
del monarca la derecha por su parte
aplaude el regreso de juan carlos porque
dicen es una persona libre y como
español puede regresar a su país cuando
quiera y nos vamos a francia con lo
último del festival de cannes donde la
guerra en ucrania ha sido la
protagonista hoy se estrenó mario police
2 un documental que muestra cómo se vive
en un barrio de la ciudad ucraniana de
mariupol bajo los bombardeos de hecho la
directora hannah biloba le rindió así un
homenaje a su prometido el director
mantas que dar a vicious quien fue
asesinado en esa urbe en medio de la
guerra área carolina piña la enviada
especial de rf y nuestra cadena aliada
nos resume que pasó en la jornada de
ayer en cara
la competencia del festival de cine de
cannes comenzó oficialmente con una
cinta histórica y un relato en lo alto
de las montañas
el director ruso kirill serebrennikov
regresó por la puerta grande al festival
de cannes serebrennikov sobre que
empezaba hasta hace unos meses la
prohibición de salida de su país el
conocido cineasta y opositor al kremlin
está aquí en la competencia con su
última película la esposa de tchaikovsky
un drama histórico sobre la mujer del
célebre compositor ruso
la cinta narra la pasión devoradora
hasta la locura de esta mujer antonina y
su matrimonio desastroso con tchaikovsky
en el siglo 19 pero también la sumisión
de las mujeres y la alienación a los
valores patrióticos
[Música]
también en la competencia este año en
cannes las 8 montañas una cinta ítalo
belga filmada a cuatro manos
[Música]
las ocho montañas narra la amistad entre
pietro y bruno en un paraíso de
naturaleza una cinta lenta que
transcurre desde la infancia hasta la
adultez entre estos dos amigos que
construyen un jardín secreto en lo alto
de las montañas
cannes deliro con la presencia de la
superestrella de hollywood tom cruise
quien vino a la alfombra roja de cannes
para presentar su última película top
con maverick 36 años después de esa
primera película que se volvió de culto
[Música]
los fanáticos gritaron cuando tom cruise
llegó al palacio de los festivales donde
recibió una palma de oro de honor y fue
homenajeado por la patrulla de francia
[Música]
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]